londres et copenhague apporteront une
aide supplémentaire à à l'ukraine des
armes d'abord la grande bretagne prête à
fournir plus de système de roquettes à
lancements multiples leur puissance de
frappe peut atteindre les 80 à km le
danemark de son côté remettra à kiev une
enveloppe de 110 millions d'euros et on
va analyser justement les enjeux les
promesses de cette conférence des
donateurs à avec vos bruno daroux venge
en revenant au journal merci d'être là
le message là qui est envoyé à kiev
c'est une volonté de maintenir la
mobilisation le soutien à l'ukraine
envahi depuis 24 février dernier par par
la russie oui bien sûr c'est l'idée de
d'entretenir ce momentum de soutien à
l'ukraine de la part des pays
occidentaux d'où cette conférence des
donateurs qui était donc organisé au
danemark même si vous l'avez dit
concrètement il n'y a que deux pays
aujourd'hui en tout cas qui ont annoncé
un renforcement de leurs soutiens
renforcement financier pour le danemark
avec plus de 100 millions d'euros et
puis effectivement la grande bretagne
qui promet de fournir ces systèmes de
roquettes de ses systèmes lance
roquettes multiples pardon qui sont
effectivement particulièrement efficace
pour viser des cibles à environ 80
kilomètres donc le message il est à la
fois très concret puisque le président
zelensky participer en visioconférence à
cette conférence de organisé au danemark
l'idée c'est clairement que le monde
occidental reste fermement en soutien à
l'ukraine et que ces armements vont
servir à l'ukraine a tenté d'organiser
des contre offensives à l'est ça paraît
difficile on assiste en ce moment plutôt
à des duels d'artillerie avec des gains
plutôt pour les russes mais tout ça
s'est fait de manière très très lente on
est presque entré dans dans une guerre
de un peu de front si vous voulez front
contre front et ça ça bouge très très
lentement notamment parce que l'ukraine
voilà et est alimenté en quelque sorte
de en armement et puis plus au sud les
ukrainiens visiblement avec ses
armements également préparent leur
contre offensive autour de la ville de
carson pour essayer évidemment ce qui
symboliquement serait important de
récupérer cette ville
il ya une réunion ce soir prévu au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
bruno à la demande de la russie qu'est
ce qu'on peut en attendre oui à
concernant notamment évidemment le sort
de la centrale unitaire de zaporizhya
qui est donc il faut le rappeler la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe avec
six réacteurs et qui a été prise par les
russes au mois de mars est évidemment
l'accusation des deux ukrainiens contre
les russes c'est qu'en fait les russes
autour de la centrale et bien hamas d
des hommes des équipements et qu'ils
savent très bien que si les ukrainiens
tirs sur les forces russes qui sont
juste autour de la centrale évidemment
potentiellement ça peut créer un
incident terrible et que donc ils
accusent les russes en fait de se servir
si vous voulez d'instrumentaliser de
manière très cynique cette centrale pour
leur permettre de bâtir un bastion ils
veulent même les russes organiser un
référendum azap aurait déjà dans cette
région pour être rattaché à la russie
voilà on voit donc l'emplacement de
cette centrale en ukraine donc
effectivement
les ukrainiens et les occidentaux et
aussi les responsables de l'aïe agence
internationale pour l'énergie atomique
demande à la russie de rendre cette
centrale à l'état souverain est légitime
à qui il appartient c'est à dire
l'ukraine on va voir ce que ça va donner
lors de la réunion du conseil de
sécurité enfin il est fort peu probable
que les russes se plie à cette demande
d'autant plus que les russes il contre
attaque en disant que ce sont les
ukrainiens qui font de la surenchère et
qui met en péril la sûreté de la
centrale merci beaucoup merci pour ces
éléments de compréhension